hello everyone I'm Jesse I want to
create a community of people that's
focused on becoming a better version of
themselves each day so if you want to
see encouraging videos while uplifting
others yourself and getting inspiration
please hit the like and subscribe so you
can see more videos like these today's
video is part of a minimalist series
where we're going to talk about ways
that you can repurpose items in your
home to reduce waste and possibly save
you money so my tip number one is
reusing your 10 jars you can also
decorate the outside like I have done I
have this jar that used to have tea bags
in it I basically chopped paint at the
outside you can choose whatever color
you like I put wax so that it doesn't
rub off and I use it now for my fresh
chamomile so kind of going along with
the Tim containers you can repurpose old
mint containers like I had these Altoid
the small Altoid containers where I
basically slapped a label on it put some
decorative tape chopping to the M
outside you can put your erasers in it
your paper clips thumbtacks I use it for
like my sewing needles and my tape
measure they're very cute and small and
organized another thing that I love to
repurpose is glass jars I had this old
pesto jar that basically surprise a
chalk painted the lid kind of a greenish
color and I made sure to put a
protective coating on the top and you
can reuse this for anything that you
like around the house I have my hemp
seeds and a peperoncini jar which I'm
going to also paint the lid on top and
it makes a very decorative statement and
reusing a jar that you already had
I also for example use a jar for my
makeup brushes and it keeps them very
organized in my face something else that
you can repurpose around the house is
your candle jars once you've used up
most of your candle jar and you just
have that little bit on the bottom you
can basically freeze it and then it
should pop out pretty easy you just use
a butter knife around it and you can put
a plant inside you can use them for
decor if you have the ones with the lid
you can store things inside great way
dish soap bottles I already had a
plastic dish soap bottle and rather than
throwing it away and just creating more
waste
I just reused it for my own home
Shampoo I am looking into cloth I
already caught Duggar but I'm gonna look
into using cloth wipes and I seen that
you can use a solution basically you
just spray it on to the cloth wipes so
maybe I'll just reuse them for that as
well if you have small spray bottles or
dropper bottles and you're wondering
what you can do with those you can use
them to make hand sanitizers or mosquito
repellent I have this one that I used to
have like an Omega vitamin in it or
something like that and I basically plan
on making mosquito repellent I just
don't have all the essential oils that I
need so it's not done yet
you can also repurpose any small cloth
bags that you may have at home I have
two other larger baggies that are like
this which is where I put my
undergarments in this one I think was
like a from a state park that we had
little rocks in and I basically use them
to put my hair bands and hair ties in so
what about plastic containers a lot of
times we can't avoid plastic containers
my husband loves a particular kind of
yogurt and so we are stuck with a whole
bunch of these containers so what I do
with them is I use them for whenever we
gift food to others or we also have
chickens so I just put eggs inside and I
give them away in this way I also on the
occasion that I do have a collection of
trash bags I don't just throw them away
I reuse them and so I keep them in here
keep them handy small plastic boxes you
can find ways to organize things around
your house for example I have this used
to be a flashlight box then I keep in
our office drawer where we just have our
pens and pencils inside and it keeps
them tidy we also make our own
toothpaste which I had this old cream or
white book bottle I don't remember what
it was I put a label on it and we have
our own toothpaste in this I love this
particular tip because if you have
random objects that you don't know what
to do with like my husband wanted to
work with leather at one point and he
made this little thing that doesn't even
fit our phone and then we have this old
gift card tin if you have kids toys you
don't really need to go out and buy kids
toys they make toys out of anything
I grew up or and I remember making toys
out of rocks so all sales maybe you can
give to your kids it is
currently mother's day as I'm filming
this my dad gave me flowers as a gift I
currently don't own any flower vases
because I prefer to have plants rather
than cut flowers but what I basically
used as the base is a mason jar
obviously it's best to just avoid having
plastic items or items that harm the
environment in our house but once
they're already there what do we do
about it the main thing that I would
love for you to take away from this is
that there is no one right way to reuse
an item you don't have to use them in
the way that I have they can serve you
in different purposes just be creative
keep your eyes open
you can do it thank you so much for
watching this video it really means a
lot to me and don't have a much
experience with this but I will get
better at it just stick with me I have a
lot of great ideas to share with you if
you found any of this information to be
helpful please remember to hit the like
and subscribe button so that we can
share more videos like this bye for now
you